c'est le fait divers qui passionne les
français celui de johnatan d'aval jugé
la semaine dernière pour avoir tué son
épouse alexia en la droguant
l'étranglant et en mettant le feu à son
corps
nous défendrons un jeune garçon qui dans
une crise de couple a effectivement
occasionné la mort de son épouse un
drame terrible d'autant que durant des
mois jonathan navals s'étaient fait
passer aux yeux de tous pour une victime
collatérale de ce meurtre prétendant ne
rien savoir
céline itunes ne manque jamais vu un
acte barbare et une trahison qui a
attisé la haine autour de johnatan il a
été condamné samedi à 25 ans de
réclusion sans peine de sûreté
un jugement qui l'a accepté et auquel il
ne souhaite pas faire appel c'est à la
hauteur de notre souffrance et ça va
faire nous permet leader de tourner une
page
si certains trouvent que cette peine est
insuffisante d'autres essayer au
contraire de trouver des mobiles avoir
des circonstances atténuantes à ce crime
c'est le cas de l'avocat pierre fabre
qui sur ces news expliquer l'acte de
johnatan par une souffrance due à une
supposée homosexualité refoulée
d'autres prennent même directement la
défense de jeunes à vannes laval en
expliquant qu'il aurait tué alexia à la
suite de disputes et une importante
pression psychologique qu'elle faisait
peser sur lui les défenseurs qui
n'hésite pas à comparer cette affaire à
celle de jacqueline sauvage qui
tuer son mari par trois coups de fusil
dans le dos mais qui avait reçu la grâce
présidentielle de la part de françois
hollande
alors comprenez vous que l'on puisse
prendre la défense de johnatan d'aval
l'avocat pierre fabre et tony a peint le
psychologue de johnatan sont sur notre
plateau pour nous éclairer sur ce
personnage si mystérieux
alors ça c'est vrai que c'est dingue de
le dire mais c'est vrai que ça passionne
ou encore jean marc morandini on va
faire une spéciale tout à l'heure dans
un instant sur nrj12 d'ailleurs nous
distrait et moi aussi je la regardais ça
c'est sûr et certain et j'ai vu voilà
tout le monde en parle de cette affaire
qui passionne les gens d'affaires daval
pire farges merci d'être avec nous vous
êtes avocat pénaliste fondateur du
capitaine des charges associées
donc c'est vous plus des associés vous
avez fait beaucoup parlé ce week-end en
évoquant certains traits de la
personnalité de jonathan d'aval est ce
que vous comprenez que certaines
personnes puissent défendre jonathan
d'aval aulas par le simple fait que nous
ne connaissons pas le mobile qui a
motivé cette personne a tué sept sa
femme
chacun pense ce qu'il veut dans un
procès pénal l'important c'est que le
délibéré satisfasse d'abord aux parties
c'est-à-dire à la défense et surtout aux
parties civiles aux victimes
dans le cas de daval temps à la famille
d'alexia que
je n'atteins d'aval était apparemment
apparemment satisfait du verdict et 25
ans de prison
25 ans oui est ce qui en réalité veut
dire qu'il fera à peu près 15 ans compte
tenu des aménagements de peine de la
détention provisoire qu'il a déjà fait
depuis 2010 est dans 15 ans à mon avis
mais alors il ya plein de gens qui
prennent sa défense qui disent qu'il a
eu une enfance compliquée acquis que son
profil psychologique on va en parler
dans un instant est compliqué ce que dit
tony arpin est-ce que vous nicolas
pernikoff vous vous comprenez pas qu'on
puisse le dire mais je ne comprends
absolument pas qu'on allait rechercher
la raison pour laquelle il en est arrivé
à faire affaire se réaliser ce cri
rageur il a quand même tué une femme
il la tue en plus dans les circonstances
incroyable comment aujourd'hui on peut
aller faire une recherche ou essayer de
le disculper de d'aller raconter qu'il
aurait une homosexualité
vraisemblablement refoulés c'est ce qui
pourrait expliquer mais je comprends
pourquoi on dit ça toutes les
informations oui ça n'excuse rien ça
permet peut-être de mieux comprendre la
famille d'alexia reste quand même sur sa
faim aujourd'hui on a l'impression que
toute la vérité n'a pas été dite
aimez vous avez dit ce que vous vous lui
trouvez des désirs conscience atteignant
puisque tout l'enjeu d'un procès pénal
c'est pas de chercher à charger ou à
atténuer c'est d'essayer de comprendre
moi j'ai tout simplement posé la
question publiquement il se trouve que
ça a fait beaucoup de polémiques et ya
beaucoup de gens qui partageaient mon
avis mais c'est l'homosexualité n'est ni
gloire ni une tare
ça ne vient pas excusé et ça permettrait
peut-être d'expliquer cet acte
irréparable que ce qu'on pensait de
l'hypothèse d'un homme soumis qui
souffrait de sa relation
ça c'est ce qui a été plaidé pendant
tout le jugement il ya un procès qui a
eu lieu une instruction qui a duré deux
ans et demi je suis pas là pour rentrer
dans la tête des jeunes attendent la
vallée vous aimez vous pour vous les 25
ans de réclusion criminelle
il est d'accord avec cette décision là
encore c'est difficile de porter le
discrédit sur une sur une d'écouté que
la justice a tranché une institution il
ya eu deux ans et demi d'instruction
les faits ont eu lieu il ya trois ans où
je me contenterai de reprendre ce qui a
été dit en par la partie civile qui a
accepté cette peine
il a trouvé juste que d'aval qu'il a
accepté tous deux n'interjettera pas
appel et je pense que c'est juste les
réquisitions du procureur était la
perpétuité à mon avis ça aurait été
complètement exagéré d'obéir à la
pression médiatique et de condamner à la
perpétuité parce que la perpétuité
c'est les violeurs d'enfants c'est les
terroristes ça n'est pas un meurtre j'ai
une question à vous poser que beaucoup
de gens se posent
si il avait avoué tout de suite voilà le
meurtre raids allaient d'alexia voilà
son jouet
toute cette comédie auprès de ses
parents sur les conférences de presse
est ce qu'il aurait une peine ce qu'ils
auraient une peine moindre parce qu'ils
ont eu la même pas je pense qu'un accusé
devant la cour d'assises est tenu à une
vérité subjective c'est à dire qu'il
essaie de se défendre comme il peut
parce qu'on porte son comportement était
humain il avait réalisé qu'il avait
commis l'irréparable il a cherché à se
défendre comme tout un chacun
peut-être que quelqu'un quelqu'un
d'autre aurait immédiatement avoué lui
pas mais je pense pas que ça qu'on en
ait tenu compte dans les débats parce
que c'est vrai qu'on va revoir une scène
1 c'est quand alors là l'enterrement on
va voir la comédie jouée par jonathan
daval et on aura avec nous tony arpin
qui a été le psychologue qui avait été
choisi pour expertiser je l'attends
d'aval merci en tout cas d'être avait
d'abord été avec une pierre farges que
je vous laisse vous avez tout de suite
sur nrj 12 va voir jean marc cozilis
regardez cet extrait merci avant de
passer à la cérémonie à l'église
un funérarium et il était votre est
littéralement sur le cercueil d'alexia
en train de pleurer
je me suis retenu de palets l'attraper
par le col pour le redresser parce que
j'étais très mal à l'aise vis-à-vis de
ce qu'ils faisaient
[Musique]
alors avant d'avoir par skype et là
c'est vraiment on a plein de questions à
lui poser tony arpin qui a été le
psychologue qui a été choisi pour
expertiser jonathan d'aval c'est
vraiment très forts de la voir ce soir
vous guillaume genton vous pouvez
comprendre
évidemment c'est impardonnable ce qu'a
fait je n'ai pas de rival mais c'est
important de chercher en tout cas lui
trouver des circonstances atténuantes
je suis un fan de faites entrer l'accusé
dans chaque épisode de faites entrer
l'accusé quelle que soit la gravité des
faits que ce soit des meurtres ou pas il
ya toujours un passage on essaie de
comprendre la vie du tueur qu'est ce qui
l'a amené à devenir comme ça et en
l'occurrence johnatan d'aval il a été
handicapé quand il était jeune il était
sourd d'une oreille droite il avait de
graves problèmes d'asthme et lui met en
avant dans sa défense le fait qu'il
aurait été frappé par sa femme à
certains moments je pense notamment à la
sphère jacqueline sauvage qui en
apparence et une femme coupable puisque
elle a tué son mari est en réalité les
actifs je vais vous dire un an et se
situe vraiment comparer ça c'est
vraiment ça c'est ça c'est inadmissible
l'encours et c'est de l'histoire moi
c'est pas mon avis c'est un parallèle
qui est fait on en a parlé dans le sujet
s'est fait par de nombreuses personnes
ce que je veux dire c'est qu'on
apparence quelqu'un peut être coupable
et là c'est le cas il l'a reconnu il va
être emprisonné et c'est normal mais
c'est normal de vouloir chercher plus
loin
oui nous on garde ça comme un comme une
série criminelle comme un feuilleton
criminels familiales et ont dit lui
c'est un méchant il doit aller en prison
et doit mourir
il ya aussi la vie d'un homme derrière
et c'est normal de s'intéresser de près
aux détails de l'affairé si c'est
quelque chose que je comprends pas c'est
que la question c'est est ce qu'on peut
comprendre qu'on traîne sa défense il ya
une différence entre prendre
j'ai trouvé ça légitime qui annexe
circonstances assez peu de circonstances
atténuantes compte sur sa taille et moi
je savais pas dire que constater la
décence et la tenait sa culpabilité sa
culpabilité je suis désolé il est
évident qu'il l'a massacrée qu elle a
agonisé qu'il a brûlé et qu'en plus il a
menti donc et paris moi je suis pas là
pour pour commenter une décision de
justice
en revanche je trouve que c'est
intéressant de malgré tout de réfléchir
à comment la justice est rendue
il y avait un magistrat qui était un
homme
il y avait ses deux assesseurs qui est
un homme et une femme et la défense de
jonathan d'alexia donc avait demandé à
ce que les jurés soient toutes des
femmes est en fait quand donc vous savez
on vote et on nomme une personne et
quand il y avait des hommes qui arrivait
et 10 et non nous on veut pas un homme
on veut une femme et donc à la fin il ya
eu donc cinq femmes et un homme donc je
me demande si tu voulais en
personne et sur les neuf personnes y
avait six femmes et trois hommes et donc
comme si la défense si vous voulez
d'alexia voulait absolument que ce
soient des femmes qui juge ce crime et
je pense que moi c'est quand même une
question si la justice doit être rendue
par des femmes
non c'est des crimes de femmes voilà
d'abord premier point la justice années
passées il a pris pour sa peine de 25
ans adam 15 ans il est dehors la famille
est d'accord donc à la fait pas appel
donc ça premier point ça après nous on
n'a pas ensemble a semblé deuxième point
pour répondre à guillaume midi la vie
d'un homme
la vie d'un homme mais la vie d'une
femme qui est morte aussi naxal existe
plus alors condamné pour ça oui mais oui
c'est ça qui est dérangeant la vie d'un
homme parce qu'il était sourd il
entendait mal d'une oreille la v6 à
l'oreille 10 à une autre alors à
l'enfance expliquait alors sur les gens
et nous des enfances difficiles ils vont
s'amuser à prendre leurs femmes à la
maintenance sûrs maintenant parce que on
parle de la préméditation là dedans moi
c'est beaucoup de choses qui me
dérangent et une amie en survêtement il
ya mis des baskets elle avale la récolte
de guerre lasse il a brûlé comme si
c'était un objet comme si c'est un mâle
est d'ailleurs remarquable
c'était une voiture volée ou non on va
voir on à tenir pas avec nous parce qu'à
mon ça c'est lui qui a expertisé
jonathan d'aval au point de vue
psychologique merci monsieur harper
d'être avec nous merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous ce soir
alors vous êtes entretenu longuement
avec jonathan d'aval est-ce que vous
pouvez nous décrire son profil
psychologique à jonathan navale vous
invitez qu'on peut le dire pour le moins
complexe complet ou deux raisons
essentielles
la première c'est parce que
effectivement on voit devant soi un
homme est en fait dans sa tête c'est un
petit enfant c'est ça même chose
également c'est que on est à faire une
personnalité qu'on appelle en fosse elle
c'est à dire qui a deux volets de
comment dire le volet qui est le volet
que l'on peut voir que l'on peut
percevoir et cette personne n'a et bien
elle n'existe qu'à travers le regard des
autres c'est à dire que je n'attends
d'aval ce qu'il a cherché en permanence
pratiquement c
l'amour d'autrui et pour ça il l'a fait
il a dit ce qu'ils pensaient qu'il
fallait faire et ce qu'il fallait dire
c'est la personnalité j'allais dire
qu'on peut voir que tout le monde a vu
que j'ai rencontré également
et puis il ya une autre personnalité qui
est beaucoup plus profonde beaucoup plus
comment dire secrète qui va se révéler
peut-être un peu plus déterminés à y
voir un peu plus agressive ces deux
personnes habilitées d'ailleurs ne vont
pas se rencontrer ou de façon
extrêmement marginale à la plupart du
temps où existent elles cohabitent mais
il n'ya pas d'interférence entre l'une
et l'autre
alors vous allez de quelqu'un de soumis
jonathan d'aval est-ce que vous pouvez
nous en dire plus là dessus c'est le
disons la physionomie qui va montrer
c'est quelqu'un qui est soumis qui a
toujours été soumis les décrit comme ça
dans sa famille dans son enfance
c'est quelqu'un qui ne sait pas
s'opposer qui ne sait pas dire non
il le dit lui-même il explique
d'ailleurs entre autres tout c'est cette
comédie qu'il a pu a instauré autour de
d'humeur par le fait qu' il n'arrivait
pas à s'assumer qu'il n'arrivait pas à
dire les choses parce qu'il était un
accès il nous a exprimé plusieurs fois
donc voilà soumis oui mais d'un autre
côté dans la manipulation et dans le
char c'est à dire qu'il arrivait à à ses
fins plus ou moins en manipulant et en
charmant son entourage
c'est à dire qu'en étant le fils parfait
le gendre idéal le mari d inde
eh bien il arrivé comme ça à exister à
travers des autres et à avoir une
représentation de lui-même qui pourrait
en quelque sorte
regardez dans une dans un billet voir
lorsque vous avez fait l' expertise de
jonathan d'aval est-ce qui vous a parlé
de la soirée où il a il a commis
l'irréparable sur sa femme alors bien
sûr qu'il en a parlé assez longuement en
donnant
certaines précisions mais il a changé
vous en rendre compte à plusieurs fois
de version mois la version qu'il m'a
donnés à l'époque c'était une crise à un
moment donné il nous expliquait que sa
femme faisait des crises régulièrement
et qu'il devait la maîtriser et que ce
soir là elle a fait une crise plus
importantes que d'ordinaire qu'il a
voulu la maîtriser et que l'accident
s'est produit c'est à dire qu en la
maintenant eh bien il a il s'est aperçu
qu'il lui avait donné la mort d'accord
alors 25 ans de réclusion criminelle
dont pour jonathan d'aval vous attendiez
à ce cette issue vous savez moi je dis
non je n'attends rien que je pouvais pas
commenter une décision judiciaire assez
bon c'est la vérité judiciaire
personne d'ailleurs ne l'a contesté
apparemment moi je n'ai pas nombre
d'opinions par un torres et dans tout
cas merci tony arpin d'avoir été avec
nous ce soir c'était extrêmement
intéressant merci d'avoir été avec nous
monsieur harper merci beaucoup merci
merci et on pourrait l'écouter des
heures 1
ce monsieur vous abordez exceptionnel
louis bernard y aura toute façon une
remise de peine ça ils sortirent en 2003
qui assure youri il va il fera que 12
ans et alors on dit de lui qu'il est
bourrée de tocs coup ça il est envahi
par les tonnes oui en fait dans sa
cellule on appelle sa cellule à lui
propre la maison de barbie
tout le monde s'en moque de lui être
parce que c'est tellement bien rangée
tellement nickel tellement propre qu on
appelle ça un tas de barbus donc un peu
de lui voilà 6 82%